all right let's let's let's let's jump
to the story for the post-millennial oh
man can't Canadian Armed Forces requires
all personnel to stop using gendered
pronouns now I mean no disrespect for
the post-millennial but I have not seen
this story anywhere else take it with a
grain of salt they say that they've seen
documents and they've linked some images
so documents obtained by conservative
commentator Aaron Gunn and presented to
the post moneill reveal that military
personnel are no longer allowed to write
he or she'd but must replace it with
they/them pronouns regardless of an
individual's preferred pronouns so first
I have to absolutely say this this
sounds so absolutely insane to me I
don't believe it sorry post-millennial
it's just too nuts yeah I don't I don't
think I agree with it either but but I
believe it is possible to the point
where I'm actually willing to read this
and go through it like huh okay like
here's not trying to say well it's where
we are nowadays with this whole thing
isn't it yeah well there's some there's
there are some images they've posted
that appear to be you know from this
document and maybe it's a little
exaggerated I don't know but the postman
has covered a bunch of stories I've seen
and the reporting tends to be you know
good as far as I can tell
let's read this and let's just talk
about gendered pronouns you know we'll
see the story says sure is a new policy
change the Canadian Armed Forces will no
longer be using gendered pronouns and
official reports they men that mentioned
the documents obtained by Aaron Gunn
they want to say issued via Canadian
Forces general message is this the edge
of a link to it let me see if I can open
this up okay what's this I'm not gonna
read through this whatever whatever this
is yeah actually let's just do this
let's do a ctrl F for gendered oh hey
hey there we go what does it say oh this
is from FAC CA it says also based on a
recent CAF cultural and normative shift
to promote gender diversity and
associated inclusiveness CFP A's writing
policy and guide will also reflect this
new reality where sex gender identity
and gender expression are prohibited
grounds of discrimination under the
Canadian Human Rights Act
fourth with the use of gender pronouns
such as quote he his and she her unquote
are not to be used when drafting pers
members will be referred to by rank and
or by using gender-neutral pronouns such
as they there okay so so hold on so it's
just a written in in like there formal
stuff they have to fill out right is
that is that what I'm understanding it's
not like la modem pers or pers is I
thought it said somewhere that it's it's
when when filling out when drafting
these things so subtracting persons you
know no personnel member jeff ting
personnel members yeah no that means so
I mean filling out all of their
information I I'm assuming that's what
it would be you know so III don't know
it's like this whole thing is such a
touchy subject so many people it's like
not not no no no no 99% of 92% of people
in this country think it's insane you're
right
this is Canada it's touchy with the
people that care about it you're right
that's really what it isn't it they can
they can call themselves whatever they
want I don't care call them floor boasts
floor Bose alright here's what here's
what here's what it says they say uh
issued via a Canadian Forces general
message these changes that deprive a
person of their sex based identity in
writing are meant to encourage gender
diversity and reports on personnel as an
event personnel no superior will be
allowed to use pronouns that designate
or refer to a person's biological sex
the notice reads based on a recent CAF
cultural normative shift are at the part
of a okay in practice superiors who are
required to write personnel reports for
those who serve under them will not be
allowed to use the pronouns of that
person's choosing if they identify as
male or female and use sex based
pronouns instead everyone will be
referred to with the accepted
gender-neutral plural pronouns of a
their them it is not yet known how
Canadian Armed Forces personnel will
react to the deprivation of their sex
based identity in their personnel
documents
that's transphobic actually if someone
doesn't if someone has born male but
identifies as she her and they refuse
that yeah see this is what I try to tell
people that they don't understand what
the results of these civil rights laws
are right here's what they wanted they
wanted to be able to say in the military
you must call me the pronouns I want the
military's response we're gonna call
everyone they then you know it's what I
said about floor bow right if you want
to be called something the only thing
not be offensive his call everybody
florabelle yep exactly how do they're
doing let's see now I wrote I see
problems arising though you have your
tweet pulled up yes pull it pull pull up
your tweet so so Tim tweeted this says
Pat and Sam are going to the movies Pat
buys tickets for a horror film because
they don't like drama Sam gets upset
because they really love drama does what
happened so what what exactly happened
who's upset and and so that so this is a
light-hearted silly example because no
no wait I would even call it silly well
this is a grammatical breakdown showing
you that I have conveyed no sufficient
information to tell you what's really
going right exactly so so then you you
switch it right let me let me let me let
me read this for you yeah Tim read your
own all right and then I'm and then I'm
gonna give you the fixed version so you
understand what really happened yeah
yeah Pat and Sam are going to the movies
Pat buys tickets for a horror film
because they don't like drama Sam gets
upset because they really love drama now
the question is is is it saying that Pat
buys horf buys tickets for [ __ ] phone
because both of them don't like drama or
only one of them who's that they refer
to is that they referring to Pat mmm-hmm
Sam gets upset because they really love
drama is that saying that Sam thinks
they both love drama that Pat loves
drama or that Sam loves drama you don't
know exactly now let me change the names
bill and Sarah are going to the movies
bill buys tickets for a horror film
because they don't like drama Sarah gets
upset because she really loves drama now
you understand what the context really
is yeah bill is under the assumption
both of them don't like drama they refer
us to the group Sam gets up Sarah gets
upset because she really does love drama
she really loves drama right because I
used they I had to use the singular of
love
yeah it's confusing the the whole plural
versus singular it's not it's not
grammatically correct so they need to
come up with something that makes sense
so in in a official report reporting
about something that's actually happened
this this is why I called that a little
silly because comparatively when they're
doing like a report of what happened
like some people got shot and murdered
or killed and something someone blew up
like I can't and whatever any sort of
military thing that's happened and
they're trying to report on it yeah
that's what they're doing let's let's
try this suddenly
everybody's are they and them let's make
it more serious Pat and Sam were
deployed on a mission in Afghanistan
yeah Pat fired several rounds after they
were startled and saw a weapon
yeah Sam got upset because they didn't
really see a weapon right now you got to
use that report in court right exam
you've got to figure out who was shot
and why that is my point and there's
gonna be some arbiter or a court you
know magistrate who's gonna be like what
is that it's saying they both saw the
weapon no sir that they only refers to
Sam but wait wait you said Pat fired
because because they saw the weapon Pat
saw the weapon yes your honor Sam didn't
really see weapon exactly yeah that they
refers to Pat Sam what they I'm sorry
I'm confused your honor me too but when
we're talking about movies it's silly
yeah but you got the military yeah how
are they gonna organize this exactly
there was this really funny viral post
from it was someone quoted Vox mmm-hmm
vox.com used someone's prefer pond Ave
okay in this context of talking about
multiple people and a group okay
it made literally no sense yeah and
we're treating it like can anyone
decipher this paragraph right and what
they do is that the people in the floor
bo people will say things like they can
be a singular and then all these
articles pop up in the dictionary adopts
it and it's like look man language is
used to convey ideas everything I'm
saying to you right now is giving you an
understanding of certain things it is
language if I started talking dog
oatmeal spoon giraffe banana cruise ship
I would call Joe Biden no idea is
conveyed imagine like imagine if I
walked up to somebody and said Oh floor
bow was mad because floor bow didn't
want to pay for floor bow self's floor
bow treatments people would be like I
have no idea what that means yes that's
the point right exactly if I'm going to
make make up words and change structure
what's the point of speaking if not
conveying any ideas yeah exactly it has
to conform to some sort of grammatical
sense or else the masses that you're mad
at for not you know for misgendering you
they don't understand because
they is plural so it doesn't make sense
so they can be singular the word they
can be singular right so if I see a
specific situation yeah right if I so if
I said you know a lawyer walked into my
room they fell down this you know a
lawyer was leaving my house they fell
down the stairs afterwards they as a
singular sore front of the person
because we don't know the gender of the
individual that makes sense or I think
you can use they for certain non
inanimate objects so if you said like a
stack of books fell over they fell to
the third page of each book it was kind
of strange or like I put a bunch of
books in the stairs then they all fell
down using they for inanimate objects
they use these exceptions wouldn't be it
also they because it's a group of books
a group of books pour right if I said I
put a stack of books on the I guess you
could say a stack is singular even
though it refers to a group you know if
I say if I said I put several books on
the stairs they all fell down
then they refers to plural the group of
books right right
so yeah they use these special
exemptions to try you know to to argue
that they can use they as a singular I
actually bring up this point in the
tweet I think I might have it where I
like here's what I said people let me
come I would actually okay let's just
jump straight down people on the right
use singular structuring structuring
with plurals but that is not how the
left believes a singular they it would
work Pat and Sam are going to the movies
Pat buys tickets for a horror film
because they don't like drama Sam gets
upset because they really loves drama if
they was a singular referring if you
know in for Sam if I said Sam gets upset
because she really loves drama loves
would have an S it would be plural right
let's see yeah because I used they it
was love look at the sentence yes Sam
gets upset because they really loves
drama it doesn't sound right no but
that's the way you would have to do it
to explain otherwise it could you could
be referring to the group right
otherwise the sentence literally makes
no sense I said the right is correct
you'd have to use the singular structure
otherwise you can't understand what is
happening in the situation but they both
secretly do they both see really like
drama is the first just pet they is
gender-neutral in select circumstances
where gender is unknown so anyway the
the story is
is interesting I think we've definitely
had a conversation about the weirdo
pronouns a whole lot yeah assuming this
is true and I know we have this site
from you know CAF - FAC CA that looks
like their website yeah I guess I mean
Armed Forces that's CA maybe whatever
this is how will they actually be able
to convey information accurately to this
- those are periods to their superiors
well I guess there's a simple thing that
needs to be said
no not to their superiors it
specifically said the only the superiors
referring to their lesser right so
they're writing reports that will go to
their superiors oh okay so if you have a
chin right if you have a commander or
something who's like here's what
happened to all my forces in Afghanistan
yeah submitting it up the chain they're
gonna be like what is this yeah what if
no idea what happened yeah but here's
the important thing to consider
no one takes the Canadian Armed Forces
seriously anyway right so I'm kidding by
the website Canadians there I'm pretty
sure Canada is part of like our
coalition or whatever isn't there Air
Force like pretty good tied with some
guy in Illinois that has oh no they were
both buying from the same place the guy
who bought three six fighter jets the
Canadian Air Force bought like 28 oh no
I know but they're they have less of an
Air Force from the guy in Illinois this
is amazing did they say in 2016 be 60 be
Bill see 16 was passed amending the
Canadian Human Rights Act it added
gender expression to the list of groups
that are protected from discrimination
as well as adjusting hate speech and
hate crime laws to include protections
for gender expression while the use of
preferred pronouns have been considered
a necessary element of the promotion
inclusion of gender diversity this
changed by the CAF is the first time
that preferred pronouns are being
officially discounted in favor of a
catch-all gender-neutral pronoun system
well what's gonna end up happening is
they're just gonna say the same person's
name specifically for every single
things they eat that's just gonna be
more work for everybody that's actually
that's that's another solution I said
going back to the sentence Pat and Sam
are going to them
movies Pat buys tickets to a horror film
because Pat doesn't like drama Sam gets
upset because Sam really loves drama you
can just get rid of pronouns altogether
no more Pro yes I can like Adam went to
the store to buy food because Adam
wanted something to eat for Adams for
for Adam because he wanted something to
eat from so I have many clones of myself
must maintain their sustenance well I'm
pretty sure most people who have watched
you like are familiar to a certain
degree with the pronoun thing maybe even
saw the tweet from me but yeah I guess
the the big development is the the
Canadian Air Force or whatever but we
also have this this is from July of to
1910 derd words ban u.s. cities code
replaces manpower with human effort this
was it a pronouncement in music human
music but this was like they're they're
trying to change gender words you know
congressperson fire people
garbage persons yeah and I know you're
all humans so he garbage person hue
process
we're just hue person hey what persons
what person a person in a wool person
like humans are we not humans can we are
we going to continue to be humans at
least because there's man in human so I
mean we're all humans right hey last
time I checked I'd like to hope so man
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you